This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When you're a comic book fan, there's always a surge of excitement when they announce a film adaptation of the character you love. The chance to see your hero punch and twist and leap to the air just makes you getty. But there's always that fear. That Hollywood is going to screw it up. That the screenwriter won't get the
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。作为一名漫画迷，当他们宣布要将你喜爱的角色改编成电影时，你总是会感到一阵兴奋。看到你的英雄挥拳、扭转、跃入空中，这让你感到无比激动。但同时也总有一种恐惧：好莱坞会搞砸它，编剧无法像你那样理解这个角色。因为你知道它本该是什么样子的。
character the way you get the character. Because you know how it's supposed to be. You know Mary Jane came after Gwen Stacy. It doesn't make sense the other way. But the first indication whether you're going to be buzzing with eager anticipation while you're in line on opening day or dreading each step while you're in line on opening day because let's face it, you're gonna go no matter what. But that first indication of how good or how bad it's going to be happens months before when they reveal the design of the suit. Superhero suits made real with real fabric and real people are very hard to design, but we will judge them nonetheless. That is our job.
你知道玛丽·简是在格温·史黛西之后出现的。反过来就不合理了。但你是在首映日排队时充满期待，还是在排队时每走一步都感到恐惧——毕竟面对现实吧，无论如何你都会去看——这最初的迹象，往往在几个月前他们公布服装设计时就出现了。用真实的布料和真实的人制作出的超级英雄服装很难设计，但我们依然会评判它们。这是我们的工作。
Either I've gotten much more mellow over the years or the suits have gotten much, much better. Eric Mullinsky has noticed this too. Eric has done a couple of great episodes for us at 9.9 P.I. over the years, but now he has his own podcast called Imaginary Worlds, about sci-fi and other fantasy genres, how we create these worlds and why we suspend our disbelief. This is an episode that he produced in 2015 about designing comic book costumes for movie screens, and I really like it and I know that you're going to like it too.
要么是我这些年变得随和多了，要么是服装确实变得好多了。埃里克·穆林斯基也注意到了这一点。埃里克多年来为我们《99% Invisible》制作过几期精彩的节目，但他现在有了自己的播客《Imaginary Worlds》，专门探讨科幻和其他奇幻类型，探讨我们如何创造这些世界以及为何会产生“怀疑的暂停”。这是一期他2015年制作的关于为电影屏幕设计漫画服装的节目，我非常喜欢，我知道你也会喜欢的。
It's called Fixing the Hobo Suit. B. Let's not stand on ceremony here. Mr. Wayne. If you haven't seen the Dark Knight Rises, Tom Hardy plays the villain, Bane. And for some reason, he did the voice as a cross between Sean Connery and Darth Vader. Given that the character is supposed to come from a fictional Latin American country, it was a very weird choice. Oh, you think darkness is your ally? Are you really adopted the dark?
这期节目叫《修复流浪汉套装》。B. 我们就别客套了，韦恩先生。如果你没看过《蝙蝠侠：黑暗骑士崛起》，汤姆·哈迪饰演了反派贝恩。出于某种原因，他把声音处理成肖恩·康纳利和达斯·维达的混合体。考虑到这个角色本应来自一个虚构的拉丁美洲国家，这是一个非常奇怪的选择。“哦，你以为黑暗是你的盟友？你真的适应了黑暗吗？”
But it was so weird. It was kind of amazing and led to all these really great parodies. I guess there. I believe I would like two packs of Chickaloo sauce. Thank you. I don't much, man. You should have respected my author at our... Woo! But for all the buzz around the voice, I was surprised more people didn't talk about the costume, which I thought was ingenious.
但这太奇怪了，简直令人惊叹，并引发了所有这些非常棒的模仿。我想……我相信我想要两包奇卡卢酱。谢谢。我不怎么……伙计。你应该尊重我的权威……呜！但尽管关于声音的讨论很多，我惊讶的是没多少人谈论服装，我觉得那设计得很巧妙。
So in the comics, Bane looks kind of like a Mexican wrestler. He's got a black hood over his face, with a white design in the middle that kind of looks like a Mexican wrestler. He's got a black hood over his face with a white design in the middle that kind of looks like a skull with red eyes. His strength comes from tubes going to his back that pump him full of liquid steroids. In fact, his shoulders are so huge and bulked out. Artists like to draw his head below his neck.
在漫画中，贝恩看起来有点像墨西哥摔跤手。他脸上戴着黑色头套，中间有一个白色的图案，看起来有点像带有红眼睛的骷髅。他的力量来自连接到背部的管子，这些管子向他体内泵入液态类固醇。事实上，他的肩膀太巨大、太臃肿了。艺术家们喜欢把他的头画在脖子下面。
There's no way he could do a literal version of that. But that didn't stop Joel Schumacher from trying in his 1997 catastrophe Batman and Robin. Behold the ideal killing machine! I call this little number. Bane. Of course, Christopher Nolan's Batman took place in kind of a semi-realistic universe. So he and Lindy Heming, his costume designer, turned Bane's liquid steroids into a gas that he enhails.
他不可能完全照搬那个造型。但这并没有阻止乔尔·舒马赫在1997年的灾难片《蝙蝠侠与罗宾》中尝试。看哪，理想的杀戮机器！我管这个小玩意儿叫“贝恩”。当然，克里斯托弗·诺兰的《蝙蝠侠》发生在一个半现实的宇宙中。所以他和服装设计师林迪·赫明将贝恩的液态类固醇变成了他吸入的气体。
But it doesn't make him super strong. It actually dulls physical pain. His breathing apparatus is the same shape as the design on the hood in the comics, but the breathing apparatus is black and the design on the hood was white. Of course, he's not wearing a hood in the movie, instead we see the actors bald head. So if you squint, Bane's head in that movie looks like the exact same design as the comics, but the negative image of it. Of course, it couldn't give Bane like cartoonishly huge shoulders, so instead he wore a coat that had a very high round wool collar that gave him the same silhouette as the comic books. Like I said, it was a brilliant design solution.
但这并不能让他变得超级强壮。它实际上是减轻了身体疼痛。他的呼吸装置形状与漫画中头套上的图案相同，但呼吸装置是黑色的，而头套上的图案是白色的。当然，他在电影里没戴头套，我们看到的是演员的光头。所以如果你眯起眼睛看，电影里贝恩的头看起来和漫画里的设计一模一样，只是负片效果。当然，他不能给贝恩画出卡通般巨大的肩膀，所以他穿了一件有很高圆羊毛领的大衣，这让他拥有了和漫画书一样的轮廓。就像我说的，这是一个绝妙的设计方案。
Superhero costumes used to be cringe-worthy. Even the cool ones like, you know, Batman from the Tim Burton films, the costume was so bulky. Michael Keaton couldn't turn his head or fight unless the bad guys basically ran into his fists. So what happened? How did the costumes get so much better? I'm Michael Wilkinson and I'm a costume designer for films.
超级英雄服装过去常常让人尴尬。即使是像蒂姆·伯顿电影里的蝙蝠侠那样酷的服装，也太笨重了。迈克尔·基顿无法转头，除非坏人基本上自己撞到他的拳头上，否则他无法战斗。那么发生了什么？服装是怎么变得好多了的？我是迈克尔·威尔金森，我是一名电影服装设计师。
Michael worked on Man of Steel and the upcoming sequel, Batman vs Superman. He got a lot of heat for the new Bat suit because the first images, it looked like Ben Affleck was wearing a thick rubber cowl and wouldn't be able to turn his head which would feel like a step backwards. But newly released images, show the dark night turning his head. I feel like hopefully when the world has a really good look at the cowl that Ben wears. I hope people like it because a lot of work went into the construction of that. There's all sorts of amazing things going on inside that cowl that make it easy to move in and have a full range of expressions. Superhero Cosm used to be just stand-alone works of fashion,
迈克尔参与了《超人：钢铁之躯》和即将上映的续集《蝙蝠侠大战超人》。他因为新的蝙蝠侠战衣承受了很多压力，因为最初的图片看起来本·阿弗莱克戴着厚厚的橡胶头套，无法转头，这感觉像是一种倒退。但新发布的图片显示黑暗骑士转动了他的头。我希望当全世界真正看清本戴的那个头套时，人们会喜欢它，因为它的制作投入了大量工作。头套内部发生着各种神奇的事情，使它易于移动并拥有全方位的表情。超级英雄服装过去只是独立的时尚作品，
which over time became dated or cringe-worthy, even if they're designed by a genius, like Edna Mode and the Incredibles. This is a hobo suit, darling. I know you can't be seen in this. That won't allow it. What do you mean? You designed it.
随着时间的推移，它们变得过时或令人尴尬，即使是由天才设计的，比如《超人总动员》里的衣夫人。“这是一套流浪汉套装，亲爱的。我知道你不能穿这个见人。我不会允许的。”“你什么意思？是你设计的。”
I never looked back, darling. The strikes from the now. It will be bold, dramatic, heroic. Yeah, something classic, like a diner guy. Oh, here it brings luck to the cape and the boots. Snuck apes! One of the big changes is that costume designers are now looking more closely at the source material. When Michael Wilkinson and his collaborator James Atchison worked on Man of Steel, they
“我从不回头看，亲爱的。那是过去的事了。它将是大胆的、戏剧性的、英雄般的。”“是的，经典一点，像个餐馆服务员。”“哦，这里，它给斗篷和靴子带来好运。”“不要斗篷！”最大的变化之一是服装设计师现在更密切地关注原始素材。当迈克尔·威尔金森和他的合作者詹姆斯·阿奇森参与《超人：钢铁之躯》时，他们
researched the history behind Superman's costume. The genesis of that idea was the circus performers, the white lifters, and the strong men had this look of wearing early wool jersey tights with their shorts over the top. So Superman's suit was kind of like a combination of the weightlifter and the ringmaster who wore boots in a cape. Also swashbuckling heroes like Zoro wore capes. So James and Michael thought, okay, that still communicates strength, power, adventure, but...
研究了超人服装背后的历史。那个想法的起源是马戏团表演者、举重运动员和大力士，他们看起来穿着早期的羊毛针织紧身衣，外面套着短裤。所以超人的套装有点像举重运动员和穿着靴子戴着斗篷的马戏团团长的结合体。此外，像佐罗这样的侠客也戴斗篷。所以詹姆斯和迈克尔想，好吧，这仍然传达了力量、权力、冒险，但是……
How are we going to resolve those silly red underpants? So we went through dozens and dozens of drawings. And I remember they pretty much just got smaller and smaller and smaller until one day they just kind of weren't there on the illustration and that was the look we decided to go with. What's the S stand for? It's not an S. On my world it means hope. Sammy Sheldon Diffor had a similar experience working on X-Men first-class. Now in the previous X-Men movies, the mutants were wearing these sort of black leather
“我们要怎么处理那些愚蠢的红色内裤？”所以我们翻阅了几十张草图。我记得它们基本上变得越来越小，直到有一天它们在插画上消失了，这就是我们决定采用的造型。“S代表什么？”“那不是S。在我的星球上，它意味着希望。”萨米·谢尔顿·迪弗在参与《X战警：第一战》时也有类似的经历。在之前的X战警电影中，变种人穿着这种黑色皮革
outfits with just a few distinguishing characteristics. But the director of first-class Matthew Vaughn told Sammy that he wanted to go back to the original comics, when the X-Men wore yellow and blue jumpsuits. So given that obviously that is a very simplistic drawing that was on the first cover, I just started researching into the period of the time, why they were drawn the way they were, what the colours were representing, and what immediately came out was, in 1963, Dupont discovered Kevlar. It felt to me like, maybe that's what they were trying to represent in the comic. So we kind of went down this route
服装，只有少数几个显著特征。但《第一战》的导演马修·沃恩告诉萨米，他想回到最初的漫画，当时X战警穿着黄色和蓝色的连体衣。考虑到第一期封面上那个非常简单的画作，我开始研究那个时代，为什么它们被画成那样，颜色代表什么，立刻显现出来的是，1963年，杜邦公司发明了凯夫拉纤维。我觉得，也许这就是他们在漫画中试图表现的东西。所以我们沿着这条路走下去，
of seeing if that would work for us, and also what NASA were up to. The advent of the nuclear age may have accelerated the mutation process. Individuals with extraordinary abilities may already be among us. She pulled that off. The costumes look cool, very 60s. But honoring the source material is tricky. Comic book illustrators, not that they don't understand, but they don't need to make a logic of the lines that they're drawing that where it goes from the front to the back of the body round over the shoulder. It just
看看这是否对我们有效，以及NASA当时在做什么。“核时代的到来可能加速了变异过程。拥有非凡能力的人可能已经存在于我们中间。”她成功了。服装看起来很酷，非常有60年代风格。但尊重原始素材是很棘手的。漫画插画家，并不是说他们不理解，但他们不需要为他们画的线条建立逻辑，比如它如何从身体的前面绕到后面，绕过肩膀。它只是
what looks cool on the page and sells the dynamic of the character. But when you put that into reality, you've got to follow those lines around the body 360. And those characters are wearing skin-tight clothes to show off their ridiculously well-defined muscles, which for some reason is completely believable in the comics. One thing we discovered is that no matter what incredible shape an actor is in, once you put a leotard on them, then everything is kind of smoothed out and all that fantastic definition that they've been working so hard at, is kind of negated. The next big leap away from cringe-worthy costumes was texture.
页面上看起来很酷，并推销了角色的动态。但当你把它变成现实时，你必须让这些线条绕着身体360度。而且这些角色穿着紧身衣来炫耀他们极其发达的肌肉，这在漫画中出于某种原因完全可信。我们发现的一件事是，无论演员的身材多么不可思议，一旦你给他们穿上紧身衣，一切都会变得平滑，他们辛苦锻炼出的所有美妙线条都被抵消了。摆脱尴尬服装的下一个大飞跃是质感。
Now in the old days comic books could only be printed in a few limited colors. That's why the costumes were usually just one or two, maybe three colors, which looked good. I mean, they kind of leapt off the page. But for a movie like Man of Steel, when to get rid of Superman's red underpants and the yellow belt, the suit is very blue, and that's boring to look at in HD. So they created a silver layer that went under the blue to give it a metallic quality, and they 3D printed texture to give it muscle definition, and a pattern of ridges which creates visual
在过去，漫画书只能用几种有限的颜色印刷。这就是为什么服装通常只有一种、两种，也许三种颜色，看起来不错。我的意思是，它们从页面上跳了出来。但对于像《超人：钢铁之躯》这样的电影，当要去掉超人的红色内裤和黄色腰带时，套装非常蓝，在高清下看起来很无聊。所以他们创造了一个银色层放在蓝色下面，赋予它金属质感，并用3D打印了纹理来提供肌肉线条，以及一系列脊状图案，这为灯光和摄影创造了视觉
interest for lighting and cinematography, and they created a backstory to explain that texture. It was chainmail. They went under the armor people wore on the planet Krypton. Another trick, which Sammy Sheldon different likes to use, is mixing and matching materials on the same costume. With the X-Men costumes, they were layers and layers of fabrics all worked into and pieced together and then, you know, connecting things one on top of the other. So, if you stand away from, they just look quite blue with yellow bits,
趣味，他们还创造了一个背景故事来解释这种纹理。那是锁子甲。它穿在氪星人穿的盔甲下面。萨米·谢尔顿·迪弗喜欢用的另一个技巧是在同一套服装上混合搭配材料。对于X战警的服装，它们是层层叠叠的织物，全部缝合在一起，然后，你知道，把东西一层一层地连接起来。所以，如果你站在远处看，它们看起来相当蓝，带点黄色，
but actually when you're going close, it's all kind of intricately stitched to make it textured and then panels and then leather pieces and then the the Kevlar in the middle. Part of design, if it's going to be interesting, is that you have to take risks. And the thing about superheroes is it's a fabulous arena to take risks. The problem is that these forms cost a huge amount of money. So you better make, you can take the risks, you better make sure that you come up with the goods because it's an awfully expensive process to get it wrong. Yeah, and a lot of very angry fans that will let you know if they didn't like it.
但实际上当你近看时，它们都是错综复杂地缝合在一起以产生质感，然后是镶板，然后是皮革碎片，然后是中间的凯夫拉纤维。设计的一部分，如果它要变得有趣，你必须冒险。关于超级英雄的事情是，这是一个冒险的绝佳舞台。问题是这些服装花费巨大。所以你最好确保，你可以冒险，但你最好确保你能拿出成果，因为搞砸了是一个非常昂贵的过程。是的，还有很多非常愤怒的粉丝，如果他们不喜欢，他们会让你知道。
Not so much the fans, it's the producers who are still waiting on the set saying, where is it? Finally, it needs to move. James Atcherson had a devil of a time working on the first Spider-Man film, the one with Toby McGuire in 2002. He spent three months making nearly 70 versions of that suit, just trying to get the colors right, making sure the textured webbing stayed on,
与其说是粉丝，不如说是制片人，他们还在片场等着说：“它在哪儿？”最后，它需要能动。詹姆斯·阿奇森在制作第一部《蜘蛛侠》电影时遇到了大麻烦，就是2002年托比·马奎尔那部。他花了三个月时间制作了近70个版本的套装，只是为了把颜色弄对，确保纹理织带保持在上面，
and when it was finally ready, they took it for a test run. We had a stunt man on a wire, and they flew him straight into a tree, I remember. And the whole suit, I mean, half the webbing unglued from the suit. I mean, it was like, it was sort of like a terrible waffle hanging in the trees.
当它终于准备好时，他们拿去试运行。我记得我们有一个特技演员吊着威亚，他们直接把他撞到了一棵树上。整套衣服，我的意思是，一半的织带从衣服上脱落了。我的意思是，它看起来就像挂在树上的一块可怕的华夫饼。
It was a disaster. It's funny, superheroes are supposed to seem indestructible. And maybe there's that scene at the very end where like after the superhero's been roughed up, his costume is like a little bit torn. But in real life, these costumes are extremely fragile. So the solution is to create 20 or 30 versions of the same costume. But each one is tailor-made for the specific needs of each scene. When Sammy Sheldon differ worked on Marvel's Aunt Man, even that wasn't enough. The suit has power, the man harnesses that power.
那是一场灾难。有趣的是，超级英雄本应看起来坚不可摧。也许在最后有一个场景，超级英雄被揍了一顿后，他的服装有点破损。但在现实生活中，这些服装极其脆弱。所以解决方案是制作20或30个相同版本的服装。但每一件都是为每场戏的具体需求量身定做的。当萨米·谢尔顿·迪弗参与漫威的《蚁人》时，即使这样也不够。“这套衣服有力量，人驾驭这种力量。”
You should be able to shrink and grow on a dime. So your size always suits your needs. They want some ones to kind of, you know, turn over and over and over. Well, I don't know what you call tumbling. And they put in a rubber floor and then they kind of go, well, he can't do it in these boots and you have to go, okay, we have to whip up a pair of boots that look identical to the hero pair,
“你应该能够瞬间缩小和变大。所以你的尺寸总是适合你的需求。”他们想要一些人，你知道，翻来覆去。好吧，我不知道你怎么称呼那种翻滚。他们铺了一个橡胶地板，然后他们说：“好吧，他不能穿着这些靴子做。”你必须说：“好吧，我们必须赶制一双看起来和英雄版一模一样的靴子，
but almost like barefoot. It's a grueling job. And Michael Wilkinson says, you really need to sort of step back and realize that this is really a conversation. It's happening across time among designers. You know in Asian art, where over the centuries you take the figure of Buddha or something like that,
但几乎就像赤脚一样。”这是一项艰苦的工作。迈克尔·威尔金森说，你真的需要退后一步，意识到这实际上是一场对话。它在设计师之间跨越时间发生。你知道在亚洲艺术中，几个世纪以来你采用佛像之类的形象，
and over the centuries they are refining, they're putting their own sort of stamp on these cultural figures. It's kind of like that I feel without making it too grand, without superheroes, because you know, each iteration of a superhero reflects a lot about the society in which the iteration was born. He's been giving this a lot of thought because he designed the first movie version of Wonder Woman, who will appear in Batman vs Superman. For Michael, this was a dream assignment. The Wonder Woman was super close to my heart growing up.
几个世纪以来，他们一直在精炼，在这些文化人物身上打上自己的印记。我觉得这有点像那样，而不必把它说得太宏大，没有超级英雄，因为你知道，超级英雄的每一次迭代都反映了很多关于这个迭代诞生时的社会。他一直在深入思考这个问题，因为他设计了《蝙蝠侠大战超人》中神奇女侠的第一个电影版本。对迈克尔来说，这是一个梦想的任务。“神奇女侠在我成长过程中非常贴近我的心。”
She was the one that really captured my imagination in the strongest way. Really? There's something about Linda Carter's performance. They really crossed into this kind of magical world. I was fascinated by her backstory. I was lucky enough to actually work with Linda Carter on a film called Sky High, where she played the principal of a high school for superheroes. So I had a kind of seminal experience shopping with her on rodeo drive that I'll probably never really get over. It was very
“她是真正以最强烈的方式抓住我想象力的那个人。真的吗？琳达·卡特的表演有一些东西。他们真的跨越到了这种神奇的世界。我被她的背景故事迷住了。我有幸在一部叫《超人高校》的电影中与琳达·卡特合作，她在里面扮演超级英雄高中的校长。所以我有一种在罗迪欧大道和她一起购物的开创性经历，我可能永远无法释怀。那非常
exciting. I mean, I think the reason why costumes have gotten so cool is because the designers are now constantly asking themselves, why? I don't think you can just get away with doing a unitalied with the funny helmet. I think you have to make sense of why is that person wearing that suit? What does he do with it? Does he have a power? Or is it something that the suit gives him? And then all those questions lead you on to, how does that work? That's one of the reasons why I love the New Daredevil series on Netflix.
令人兴奋。我的意思是，我认为服装变得如此酷的原因是设计师现在不断地问自己：为什么？我不认为你只穿一件带滑稽头盔的连体衣就能蒙混过关。我认为你必须解释为什么那个人要穿那套衣服？他用它做什么？他有超能力吗？还是那是衣服给他的？然后所有这些问题都会引导你：它是如何工作的？这就是我喜欢Netflix新版《夜魔侠》系列的原因之一。
In the first season, there are actually separate episodes to answer all those questions. Why does he need fighting sticks? Why does he need a padded suit? Why does the suit have to be red? Why does it have horns? My grandmother, she was the real Catholic. She used to say, be careful of the Murdoch boys, they got the devil in them. The evolution of Daredevil's costume becomes the story of the character realizing who he truly is. The costume is like an expression of his real self, the one that he has to dig down and find below the surface of his alter ego, Matt Murdoch. The best costume designers are storytellers.
在第一季中，实际上有单独的剧集来回答所有这些问题。他为什么需要战斗棍？他为什么需要加垫的套装？为什么套装必须是红色的？为什么它有角？“我祖母，她是真正的天主教徒。她常说，小心默多克家的男孩，他们心里有魔鬼。”夜魔侠服装的演变变成了角色意识到自己真正是谁的故事。服装就像是他真实自我的表达，那个他必须深入挖掘并在他的另一个自我马特·默多克表面之下找到的自我。最好的服装设计师是讲故事的人。
The fans will nitpick, but I don't really feel like there are any wrong choices. So long as they make us believe something that's wonderful and ludicrous at the same time. I remember spending many, many, many nights in a loft in Manhattan trying to get the right color screen printed onto those suits. So New York is my favorite city in the whole world. Yeah, that's great. It's funny too because I'm because of those films, those Spider-Man films, when I walk around New York and I've lived here now for 11 years, every so often I look up and I just imagine how great it would be to see Spider-Man swinging through those those canyons of skyscrapers
粉丝们会吹毛求疵，但我真的不觉得有什么错误的选择。只要它们让我们相信一些既美妙又荒谬的东西。我记得在曼哈顿的一个阁楼里度过了许多许多个夜晚，试图把正确的颜色丝网印刷到那些套装上。所以纽约是我全世界最喜欢的城市。是的，那太棒了。这也很有趣，因为因为那些电影，那些《蜘蛛侠》电影，当我走在纽约时——我现在已经在这里住了11年了——每隔一段时间我就会抬头看，想象如果能看到蜘蛛侠在那些摩天大楼的峡谷中穿梭该有多棒。
Yeah Seriously, it kind of bums me out that we don't see him up there every so often going Now go on, you're no suit will be finished before your next assignment. You know I'm retired from hero work. As am I, Robert. Yet here we are. E, I only need a patch job for sentimental reasons. Fine. I will also fix the hobo suit. You're the best of the best.
是的，说真的，我们没能经常看到他在上面飞来飞去让我有点沮丧。“好了，走吧，你的套装会在下次任务前完成的。”“你知道我从英雄工作中退休了。”“我也是，罗伯特。然而我们却在这里。”“E，我只是出于怀旧的原因需要修补一下。”“好吧。我也会修复那套流浪汉套装。”“你是最好的。”
Yes, I know, darling. Fixing the hobo suit was produced by Eric Mullensky for his show, Imaginary Worlds. Right now, he's in the middle of a five-part series about the cultural impact of Storm Wars. Of course he is. It's a really great show. Find it at ImaginaryWorldsPodcast.org.
“是的，我知道，亲爱的。”《修复流浪汉套装》由埃里克·穆林斯基为他的节目《Imaginary Worlds》制作。现在，他正在制作一个关于《星球大战》文化影响的五部分系列节目。当然他会这么做。这是一个非常棒的节目。在ImaginaryWorldsPodcast.org找到它。
So Eric and I both really love the music of Melodium, aka Laurent Gerard. Laurent turned 40 this year and released a new Melodium Electro album to celebrate called Friendly Vehicles. Right now that album is pay what you want on V Bandcamp or you can get all 29 of his albums for 88 Euros, which is insane to me. It's totally worth it. Make sure you let me know if you buy his whole discography because you and I should be Twitter friends at the very least if you do that. Get more melodium in your life at melodium.bandcamp.com 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan Kurt, we're all on Twitter, Tumblr, and Instagram and Spotify.
所以埃里克和我都很喜欢Melodium，也就是Laurent Gerard的音乐。Laurent今年40岁了，为了庆祝发行了一张新的Melodium电子专辑，叫《Friendly Vehicles》。现在那张专辑在Bandcamp上是“随心付”，或者你可以花88欧元买下他所有的29张专辑，这对我来说太疯狂了。这绝对值得。如果你买了全集一定要告诉我，因为如果你那样做了，你和我至少应该成为Twitter好友。在melodium.bandcamp.com获取更多Melodium的音乐。《99% Invisible》有Sam Greenspan, Kurt，我们都在Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram和Spotify上。
But you can listen to every single episode of 99% Invisible at 99pi.org. Radio til the end. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你可以在99pi.org收听《99% Invisible》的每一集。广播直到最后。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。